actually like i think for a guy of value
like you should do more
to be honest
a guy
no like a guy that you felt like a guy
that you like want and like want to
compete for like i think you should like
what i have never been one to compete
for a man ever
yeah but you also like you you've never
had a boyfriend right yeah so it's like
i think like
like in order to like get because even
um
with one yeah like when i would ask him
like what made me like stand out from
like other girls you know i like he said
um
it was like because you were so nice and
like so helpful
because i was like helping him with all
of this stuff like
you know before we were even like dating
you know
um so i don't know that's just like so
why do you think like you shouldn't do
anything for a guy because men want to
do for you
men as
men
want to do for the woman right they are
the ones that need it they want to feel
like they can come in and provide for
you and and help you do stuff and if
you're doing everything for them they're
not really going to feel like there's a
place for them and then you also end up
in a room where they walk all over you
and expect you to do everything for them
and then you become their mother and not
their girlfriend right well no i
definitely agree with you there but i
think it's like you kind of meet in the
middle somewhere okay like i think like
if you want him to treat you like a
queen you have to treat him like a king
sure so like you know like like which
means like buying him gifts unexpectedly
or like cooking for him cleaning for
like you know and i'm not saying you
have to do that like your full-time job
but like i think guys want to be like
appreciated
so i mean i cook i mean you know because
you came to my house yeah oh my gosh
you're a great cook actually
that's like nothing
like anybody anytime anyone's coming
over like man female whoever like
you're gonna have food today by me so
like i guess that already gives me up so
i don't have to think about that uh yeah
and sure like once i point where i'm
living with my man i'm gonna be doing
the cooking and cleaning most likely
because
i want it done a certain way
so i'm just okay it doesn't bother me
but when we're in recording stages
what i'm doing for you i'm giving you my
time i'm spending time and i'm telling
you appreciation by showing up looking
good and smelling good and if that's not
enough for you it'll be for someone else
oh my gosh no
i like i think like no okay because okay
think about it like if you have like
let's say you have a guy and he's
talking to like three different girls
right
like i i like genuinely and genuinely
think like if you're the one that's like
going out of your way to like make him
feel special like you're gonna have a
leg up over like the other two girls
rather than the one who's just doing
nothing okay even in like the courting
phases so like like imagine if you like
dropped off like this is a guy he's
talking to three different girls but
you're the one who made him like a
special gift right and you just drop it
off at his work to be nice
like i bet that's gonna go a long way
i don't know okay this is an example
that it didn't happen to me but
um the most recent season of the
bachelor with the guy matt james right
in his like final three the chick one of
the chicks
made him
special like
jerseys that said mr and mrs james and
she got him this whole little gift and
this is before he like got down in the
final two and she was like you know i
just really wanted to tell you how much
i appreciate you how much i you know i'm
falling in love with you blah blah blah
he was like thank you for the gift and
broke up with her in that moment and
then wait oh is that michelle yeah
and then he picked the chick who did
literally nothing who sat in the corner
and was quiet the entire time
yeah but i think he liked her from the
beginning like i think like
oh it doesn't really like if they like
you they like you you don't have to do
all the extras to like sway them into
liking you
like
when that happened it was such a cringe
moment because i was like man she really
thought she was about to be mrs james
she got all this [ __ ] monogrammed and
everything and he was like
and he literally just left her like
right there
yeah but that's like reality tv you know
like that's not like really men and
women okay i'll give i'll give you an
example right my mom and my this is how
my mom got to date a guy in the top half
a percent of men okay right i mean he
was like like in terms of income right
and she she was um
i mean granted he didn't
make that money then right but like my
dad's always been a hard worker any girl
that's met him like at a young age like
they'd be able to tell
um she was dating my dad they were doing
distance because they met like in texas
it's a long story they met my
my my uncles
and my aunt were engaged and they
brought each other to like me right
so that that's how they met and then
like they broke up the engagement but my
parents like ended up getting married
later does that make sense
okay yeah so they they like both stayed
with like my uncle and my aunt for the
summer that's how they met when like
then they lived two hours apart but did
distance and my dad told my mom he said
look you can either move to me or you
can find a new boyfriend
but and that's what you said she said
you know what like this is a guy that i
want to be with i'm going to drop what
i'm doing and go follow him and then on
top of that like she also gave up her
career she was going to be a teacher
and she said you know what like you need
help in your business i'm going to go do
that and like that's how she got like a
top percentage of man is because
like other girls would probably say no
i'm not i'm gonna put like myself first
i'm not gonna like give this up for you
but because my mom was like selfless and
she said you know i'm gonna go follow
you and i'm gonna like you're the leader
like then now she has 10 kids lives in a
mansion and like is a multi-millionaire
like i love that it was it wasn't by
just like sitting back and doing nothing
doing nothing yeah
that is
and that's a great perspective on it
yeah and like and i think like a lot of
times like as women like we look at
girls that don't have to like
like do anything and like sometimes that
exists like there's a girl that's just
like super pretty or super like pretty
privileged is like real right like girls
like that are super models that they
just don't have to do anything but like
i like personally think like
like where i consider myself like cute
like that's where i think i fall i think
there's a million cute girls so what can
you do to stand out like i think if you
do more like
you'll find someone at some point that
gives you more back because just men are
like not used to having a girl that like
really appreciates them
i think for me personally i tend to
overdo it right like
it would turn it would go from me like
dropping off a cute gift at your job to
me
like obsessively being like can i do
your laundry can i make you dinner can i
do this and it would i wouldn't know
where to stop myself okay fair enough
yeah
so like especially right now at the
place where am i where i'm at
i'm gonna go down that road until i'm
more
steadily seeing one person
then yeah
all those things back and forth but when
we're we're both still kind of like
i don't know in the very beginning
stages of dating each other especially
while i'm dating multiple guys yeah
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna take that
initiative to do those extra things
um
but i mean that's a little different how
long did your parents date long distance
for
oh they they dated for
i want to say like two years distance
before they like
and he was like look you can either like
because she transferred schools like to
be with him
so
that's after like they've been in there
i'm sure they were exclusive after the
like you know somewhere in those two oh
yeah they were exclusive like within a
couple like a month or two it's a little
it's a little bit different but i
totally hear what you're saying yeah
she had to make the leap she had to put
the effort into you know take that extra
step yeah
well i just think sometimes like as
women were so afraid of like looking
dumb you know like putting in all this
like effort and just like it blowing up
in our face you know like that's what
i'm always used to always be afraid of
but like
i don't know like i think for like the
right person like you're not gonna look
dumb they're gonna appreciate it yeah
yeah i agree but it's it's you're using
your discernment to know like who is
that right person and at what time is it
right to do those things yeah yeah
no fair enough fair enough yeah
um is there any other topics you want to
talk about
um
we should talk about cuffing season
that's what i'm all about right now
cuffing season
how are you are you in the do you have
any prospects i do one of them was one
of the ones that was texting me just
before messing up the live
oh yeah
what is he like how old he's 39
and
he's white
he
has like a corporate job
okay
he's nice and he's not like
i just went away for a week for like a
work trip and he's not like blowing up
my phone like being annoying which is
really nice i need that sort of sort of
space
back he's immediately like i'm gonna
let's celebrate like i want to take you
out and i'm like oh
how many how many dates have you guys
gone on one okay yeah we went on one
right before i left that was our first
first date it's a date
go ahead sorry so now we'll go i guess
on the second one
but he's kind of short he's only like
five nine
oh that's you're you're what like five
i'm five eight that's tall enough right
not really
you know manifesting a tall man one of
the other guys i'm talking to is six
foot seven
oh wow
yeah
um and we'll be going out soon it's just
a matter of like scheduling we just
haven't been able to like link on the
schedules we both work a lot
mm-hmm
there's another guy who i just made this
whole take a tick tock about who
was like all about me asking me out
calling me all these pet names my love
and all this [ __ ] and then we're talking
and i was like oh you have the vaccine
right and he was like no
i was like you're not vaccinated and you
want to go out with me i'm like i'm not
going out with you you're not vaccinated
what are you [ __ ] kissing you you're
not vaccinated i'm like
really oh i wouldn't care i don't care
in too many arenas where you have to be
vaccinated like i work at a yoga studio
where we're requiring proof of
vaccination that's where i am right now
clothing always laundry i own all these
music festivals where they're requiring
proof of vaccination and to me it's so
much deeper than just like do you or
don't you it's about that like i don't
want to have that debate with you right
like clearly if we don't view it the
same way we're not in alignment
right
so would you not would you not date
someone that was different than you like
politically no i wouldn't what are what
are your standards like what are your
requirements for a guy
i mean politically i definitely want us
to have the same view you know i'm a
black woman right so i'm not gonna date
a white republican that would just be a
headache like why would we do that to
ourselves
okay same friends we wouldn't travel in
the same circles and we don't view this
the world the same way so i want to use
the world the same as me and even if
you're not black but you're white and
you like get and understand the black
struggle fine
um but yeah i definitely want them to
have the same political views as me
because it's just
why bother and having those arguments
okay i'm just gonna turn into a fight
later
yeah no so what like what else
[Music]
well they have to have a car this other
guy who didn't have a vaccine he didn't
have a car i was like how are you coming
to take me out you don't have a car you
know i'm not driving anywhere yeah
so that's like minimum requirement you
have to have a car um i've also realized
that i want someone that has like some
sort of creative or like
job and entertainment like i have
um
you have to be very ambitious because i
am very ambitious i want to people like
you know we'll spend our days or
whatever separately and then at the end
of the night i want us to be able to
come together and talk about all of the
exciting things that happen in each of
our lives right like okay this other guy
was like well i'm not rich i'm a regular
guy and i was like that's fine but like
i'm not a regular girl
i'm i'm not so like
if you are gonna date me like either you
gotta be able to handle that or you
yourself also wants to not be like
regular like i don't think
like just an average person like that to
be boring
okay so
is there like a do you care okay would
you be cool with a guy that makes less
money but he's very he's a hard worker
like he's ambitious
yeah
okay so like if he was making like
let's say he just started his own
business but he makes forty five
thousand a year would you date him
you wouldn't be able to afford my
engagement ring i'm getting an eight
carat cushion cut vintage engagement
ring if you make forty five thousand
dollars a year it would take what
four years no eight years to afford how
much
i don't know anything about ranks how
much how much is that about two hundred
thousand dollars girl you want a two
hundred thousand dollar are you insane
my ring has to sparkle from across the
street like you have to see that [ __ ]
that's so superficial that's like so
superficial but it's about so much more
than that it's about the fact that you
can afford that right i go to yoga with
this girl who has an eight carat diamond
engagement ring yeah the weed company
and drives an audi
so it's about more than just it's about
the fact that you can afford that
okay well i'm just thinking like
you're gonna miss out on a lot of guys
because i'm telling you
but not not in a good way not in a good
way i'm telling you like my dad would
but if my mom asked for that from my dad
my dad would have told her to go find a
new boyfriend because there was no way
in hell he was going to spend 200 000
dollars on an engagement ring and that's
no and that's a multi-millionaire in the
top half a percent who had 10 kids my
mom never
he said he's built to the becoming that
he wasn't that originally right
he wasn't well he was making like six
figures in his early 20s oh nice so so
any any women woman with half a brain
would think this is a good this is a
good but my dad's like he's good with
money he's not like like to me that's
like such an unwise investment to spend
200k appreciate
oh my god no no
oh my god no
that's like i would rather put that in a
college fund for our kids or like yeah
they'll have that too
but this just sounds like not like real
to me you know really yeah like i don't
know for me like i told you like my my
status is going up like i just did a
music festival where i made 30 grand
over there in one weekend you know what
i mean like i need somebody who can be
on that level right but the problem is
like guys don't care about your money
right
there
i i know but it doesn't like
you know like
i'm just i think you're going to miss
out on a lot of guys with like this crew
like to me these are like crazy high
standards so
today i listened to my dating coach
she said you do not get your expectation
you get your minimum standard
who is your dating coach married yes and
she has a baby and her wedding ring is
at least five carats yeah
and her man is rich excuse me okay you
know he herself makes like 30 to 50
grand a month
coaching women in love i mean good luck
if that like works for you i just like
to me that sounds like
a 200k engagement ring like i think like
guys are going to hear that and be like
no
no no you have to have the man who's
okay with maintaining you
right with maintaining you right like
you can be high maintenance but if you
are dating a man that is okay with
maintaining you you're fine you're not
high maintenance then you're just on
their level
okay but i'm i'm just thinking like
like
i i know but those guys that are making
like
like that amount of money like
like i think they typically want like
the young like 21 22 year olds
i don't think so
what
i'm 30. so i'm not that old i'm actually
no i don't age to be wiped up by
somebody who's like in their 40s and
like ready to be serious and start
popping out babies a 21 year old unless
you're kylie jenner is realistically too
young to be like popping out kids
like you're too young
yeah i mean that's just i'm sorry the
200 000 like that's crazy to me
that's like
oh my gosh i cannot believe that's crazy
being someone that can make that amount
of money in a shorter period of time
like somebody who would say a musical
artist right a musical producer somebody
who's in entertainment somebody who's on
a tv show somebody who
does like concerts and tours that amount
of money
isn't
the same
to them you know what i mean what do you
what do you mean
like say i was dating somebody like a g
eazy right okay he makes 150 000 minimum
per show minimal that's what he makes in
a show yeah so if he does a couple shows
the 200 grand to him he won't even feel
it
no but like this is something coming
from someone like i've been in a
relationship with a guy that was worth
over a million
like i but i would never in a million
years ask him to spend 200k on a rank
like to me that's like that's almost
like entitled like i'm not entitled to
his money
i mean
here's the thing if i can afford it
myself
i will i would want you to be able to
get it for me right yeah get it myself
wow oh my gosh that's just
yeah i guess like we kind of probably
have different like views on like
spending habits because to me i'm like i
would even if i had the money i would
never spend that on a
ring but i'm also not that much of a
jewelry person right so it's like you're
not gonna need to be buying me diamonds
for every anniversary or
jewelry all the time like get me my ring
and that's